(light music)
- [Narrator] While it
looks like tree bark,
there is more here than meets the eye.
This is Madagascar's
mossy leaf-tailed gecko.
(light music)
There are few animals in
the world that exhibit
such incredible camouflage as a
mossy leaf-tailed gecko.
Growing up to six inches in length,
their bodies are lined
with small flaps of skin
that help scatter their shadows,
making their outline nearly
invisible to predators.
Endemic to Madagascar, these
geckos spend their lives
on the trunks and branches
of dense rainforest fauna.
Nocturnal in nature, they use their
elliptical shaped pupils
to hunt for insects
and small invertebrates
in the dead of night.
In spite of their formidable camouflage,
the mossy leaf tailed gecko's future
is threatened due to deforestation
and increasing demand in the pet trade.
This is the mossy leaf-tailed gecko.
(light music)